let's go to the phones and see what is
going on why don't we start with at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 let's start with Caesar
from San Antonio Caesar from San Antonio
go ahead hello yeah that's you I have a
question I wanna ask ya that you know we
are averaging more than one mass
shooting every day now and a lot of them
seem to get worse I mean do people feel
so irate in and stressed out about their
lives and that they need to shoot up
their workplace or school because I
can't imagine a classmate or a co-worker
for that matter just go one day wake up
and say I'm telling everyone tomorrow
and actually doing it well I mean I
think that I that that's the problem
right that even though when we think of
our own lives maybe some of us do know
people where we would say you know I
actually can think of a couple of people
who might choose to solve problems or
try to solve problems by shooting others
most of us would say I don't really know
people who would do that and yet as you
point out we're having dozens of
shootings a day and minutes some of
those are mass shootings a lot of them
individual shootings so the problem I
think is a multi-faceted one people who
say that the problem is only guns or
wrong but guns are part of the problem
people who say that mental health is the
only problem are very wrong because
mental health with access to very lethal
firearms are extraordinarily problematic
but part of it is the cultural aspect of
when there are problems thinking about
using guns to try to solve them and
that's something that is bigger than
mental health and it's bigger than gun
safety although those are important
things and yeah I mean - a lot of people
think of doing exactly that Cesar that's
the problem too many people are saying I
have a problem that I've identified I
have a grievance I'm going to obtain or
I already have firearms and I'm gonna do
something with them because of what I'm
feeling and that's what we need to
change culturally I'm like what would
you like
would you do it feel like if you found
out someone that you that you personally
or close to you that that was gonna like
kill people like I found out that they
were planning on doing it or if I found
out that they had done it like they were
planning on doing it it depends on the
situation but first I would assess try
to assess for myself is this for real
and if it is I would let the police know
I mean what what it would be immoral not
to I would have to do that it would be
difficult if it's a close friend imagine
if it's a family member but I could not
in any way live with myself not doing
something if I know someone is thinking
about going out there and harming other
people
mhmmm I remember I still remember like
many years ago I'm also um young enough
to remember Columbine when that happened
yeah that was shocking yeah I mean it's
unfortunately if if Columbine happened
today I think we would not be nearly as
shocked like Michael Moore wouldn't do
another documentary a documentary about
one shooting now would seem pointless
because in the time that you're
producing the documentary there would
probably be a handful more similar
shootings and that I think that's that's
a good point Caesar that points out just
how bad it has gotten a Caesar
appreciate the call thank you so much